Good morning to all of you.
Yesterday we met
finally
the agreement between the socialist party and yunsper
Proposal to unblock the investiture
and carry out amnesty
that allows definitively dejudicializing
the conflict between the state and the.
We thus note
that exists at this time
1 plurinational and democratic majority,
although not progressive,
in the rejection of the deputies
and that is undoubtedly good news for our country.
However,
I do not forgive you my enormous concern
by the images we are seeing these days
in the streets of Madrid.
I deeply respect that the citizens of our country,
think what you think,
manifest peacefully.
The problem is that what we are seeing is something else.
What we are seeing these days
is the resurgence of a coup strategy
that the political right,
media and judicial
has been deploying in our country for a long time.
Demonstrations in front of socialist headquarters
and in front of the mirror
are full of aggressiveness,
of violence,
speeches and proclamations of hatred
with numerous people of neo-Nazi ideology
and ostentation of pre-constitutional symbols,
and they meet
from the eviction parapolice commando
to communicative pamphlets
that have been encouraging for years
the coup against a legitimately elected government.
And yet,
these mobilizations are just the tip of the iceberg.
Let's remember how during these years
reactionary sectors have been allowed to
control the general council of the judiciary,
the highest governing body of judges,
with the expired mandate
e in breach of the Spanish Constitution
without anyone doing anything
and despite having a majority in the championship.
To avoid this
the fishing sector was allowed to
of the Constitutional Court
to deal 1 judicial blow to the legislative branch
preventing 1 vote in the Senate,
something that is unprecedented
in the democracy of our country.
Far-right pamphlets were allowed to
roam freely
in Congress.
It has been allowed that
on the same Spanish Radio and Television
and on all other televisions,
but particularly in the public one,
lies about 1 political force in the government
as is we can
and permanently spread hoaxes about us.
Today all
we stand in solidarity
with the attacks on the headquarters of the Socialist Party
and it is very good to do so.
That is what we have to do.
But where was the socialist party
and progressive media
when 1 teacher was being harassed
and 1 Minister of the Government of Spain
in your home where 3 small children live?
A long time ago
we should have started
to stop the right-wing coup strategy,
especially
when we had an absolute majority
in the congress of deputies.
We hope it will not be too late.
The strategy of not saying anything because it doesn't happen to me,
is dangerous and ends up taking its toll.
What we are seeing is dangerous,
but not for us or for the Socialist Party.
1 danger to democracy
and especially for collectives
that are always at the point of Mira
of hate speech and violence,
women,
LGTBI people,
irracialized migrants,
those who think like us
and dare to say it out loud.
Unfortunately
I have to say
that the socialist party
has decided to start this legislature
with a very bad foot.
To confront these rights is fundamental,
fundamental,
that the democratic bloc has,
first,
block consciousness.
And yet,
we can only
is thinking beyond his partisan interests.
Everybody knows that the socialist party
does not make amnesty
out of conviction,
but by obligation,
just as the housing law had to pass,
feminist laws,
the gas cap or the reduction of public transportation
because
we could have enough strength to demand it.
We need more height of sight.
We need all parties to
of the democratic bloc
understand that we have a lot at stake
and that we are all necessary,
especially the engine we can,
that has demonstrated
in these years
being the one who brings courage
and the necessary transformation capacity.
Or does someone think
that the women would have felt questioned
to go out to vote
en masse against the right
if it weren't for
because they have felt that the coalition government
has also fought for them
in this adverse context.
"I believe it is my responsibility as governor general.
"
basically tell you the truth,
3 months have passed
since the general elections were held
of the 23rd that day,
Thanks to massive mobilization
of progressive people
of Our country,
y Thanks to the fact that on the internal level
we can made 1 exercise of responsibility
unprecedented in Spanish politics,
we all achieved together
democratically curb the right wing.
In all this time
the socialist party has been completely isolated
of something so basic,
so basic,
so minimally respectful among members,
as is
to respond to the 5 proposals that we can have made
to achieve 1 courageous government
and stable,
1 government that takes the next legislature seriously
and to continue to really deepen
social transformations,
feminist and democratic
that our country needs so much.
The Socialist Party and President
seem completely determined
to form a government in which only they are in charge,
in which they impose all decisions.
I regret to inform you that at this time
practically
none of the requests from Podemos have been met.
and that since there is no
no or government agreement
between the Socialist Party and we can,
at this time
I must submit to the bases of we can,
those who really rule this organization,
the decision of whether or not to support
exclusively the investiture of Pedro.
In my opinion,
despite everything,
our vote has to be yes,
mainly
to respect the mandate of progressive citizenship
July 23,
who said loud and clear
that he did not want the right wing to govern.
But I don't understand you
that I am enormously sick
for the direction in which the socialist party
starts this new legislature,
the Zoe is being enormously irresponsible,
renouncing to have we can
in the construction of the block
plurinational and democratic.
Today I want to remind the socialists
that people voted for them
for more than just amnesty,
no matter how necessary Sean is.
And this one certainly is.
But people are waiting
that we do something with the rental price
of food,
that we drug the gag law and above all,
that we continue to advance courageous feminist policies.
The socialist party is wrong
disregarding the engine we can,
because we can has been the force
that has proposed the measures
most ambitious of this legislature
and more important than that,
he has achieved with his persistence and conviction,
that these measures become a reality.
To lead it is not enough to impose,
it is necessary to convince.
To confront these right-wingers
we have to continue to advance in rights
to confront these coup right-wingers,
as we are seeing these days.
1 government in which only Mandelsoe is enough,
we need 1 brave government with we can.
Podemos,
if so decided by the registered members,
VA to put 1 more time
ahead of its interests as a party,
the interests of the people of our country,
as already happened in 2018,
giving our votes for free to the socialist party
to remove Mariano Rajoy from the Moncloa,
as happened in 2 019 when Pablo Iglesias
Gave 1 Step to 1 side
to leave the socialist party
no excuses
to prevent the first coalition government
of Our recent democracy
and also
as included in the pre-electoral agreement to consummate
to guarantee that in which we will not even have
nor Diaz believed,
the repetition of the coalition government.
The problem
is that no matter how much responsibility we have,
we can,
if the socialist party persists in its mistakes,
the right will eventually pass.
Thank you very much!